this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrass
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and today's episode is cosmic queries
the out there edition we're talking
about
not just astrophysics but the extremes
of astrophysics
in space time and dimensions
while i have some expertise in that
topic i don't have all the expertise
necessary to pull this off
so we called in my friend and colleague
jenna levin jenna
okay thank you for coming i love being
here not your first rodeo
yeah not my first radio net but i
haven't been in your office in a long
time okay well it's just
it's gotten messier just what you know
in kind of a good way almost
like uh i don't know curatorial way
curatorial way
and helping me bring some levity to this
topic uh
is the one and only harrison greenman
harrison how you doing welcome
i do think we need to get marie condo up
in here do you have to see which thing
spark joy
it all sparks joy there's a
conflagration of joy
get the hell out of my office exactly
we'll barricade it we'll barricade it
so uh uh you're a comedian and a
magician yes
absolutely that's crazy oh yeah dude
stay here i don't want you to play
double threat don't make my guests
disappear today right
i use my powers for good i'm a good
witch and so uh we'll find you harrison
greenbaum.com yeah
your tour schedule and everything and
also maybe comedy central will book me
if this is my website.com
which i did register oh really
we all froze for a second it's a very
long domain for some reason it was
available
there's a real beat there so janna
you're an expert on on
on the large-scale universe on black
holes
um your recent book was the black hole
blues
yeah you know you said it better than
anyone ever i once got you to say the
whole title which you might not remember
was black hole blues and other songs
from outer space
and you did your best dj voice nail i
can't i don't even know if i have it
recorded really
yeah let me try it again the black hole
blues
and other songs from outer space and
other songs
the black hole blues and other songs
from outer space
does that work for you okay put that on
your ringtone
exactly i'm a big fan of the blues in
general so i was i was enchanted by the
title
uh so harrison if you remember this is
also not your first rodeo but yeah uh
you're not a regular on the show
uh for cosmic queries we solicit solicit
questions
from our fan base through all the social
media channels and then some
and you the co-host are the only one
who's seen these questions i haven't
seen them jan hasn't seen them
and you're just going to read them and
jana and i will try to answer them
and we can't answer we'll just say i'll
say i don't know she's not going to say
i don't know
oh yeah i might just make some stuff
who's gonna who's i'm gonna call your
stuff i'll i'll maybe i'll call you out
on it by then i'll be home
[Laughter]
so harrison so what do you have for me
if you haven't seen these i could just
be making these up
that's true that would be hard though i
think yeah yeah all right all right so
we'll start with that good people who
listen to our stuff so
that's the first question says how do
you make harrison a regular that came
from my mom
definitely on the sheet um no so here's
a patreon question
patreon yes oh so you out of all those
questions you went found the patreon
question and put it first
absolutely every time that is kissing
ass you realize this gotta do it
okay zachary spradlin from patreon and
thank you for supporting
uh the question is given your vast
knowledge of physics
i'm sure they're talking to me um what
are your thoughts on a holographic
universe would 100
empirical evidence of a holographic
universe change how you behave on a
day-to-day basis
imagine if we could access the universal
holographic database
that's a good one that's like a
three-parter
i've tried to fully understand the
holographic universe and i only kind of
skim the surface so if you have a deeper
spectacular if you have a deeper sense
of this i would totally want to know
yeah it's not something i specifically
have worked on but i pay very close
attention
to it in the hopes that one day i'll
have a good enough idea to actually jump
in the fray
okay so the way that um just to be clear
so when you do your work you're a
theorist
yeah and you're very pen and paper yeah
old-fashioned old-fashioned
totally old-fashioned kind of paper so
you're really cheap
non-expensive science if you want to
give me a grant i can do my research
a couple thousand dollars seriously
lowest level in terms of equipment and
supplies
i think somebody will buy you a macbook
i feel like somebody else is getting at
least an ipad
yeah and that's only to check my social
media a very large iphone we can get
this definition
you and i got this we got this so so you
just just so people know
yeah you're professor of astrophysics at
barnard college in columbia university
yeah which is right up the street here
right at the street
okay so so go on so so um the
holographic universe
so hologram the whole idea of a hologram
is that you really have two-dimensional
information
but it creates the illusion of being
three-dimensional that's just what a
hologram means yeah because when you
look at it like yeah
your your credit card might have a
holographic bird on it right but it's a
object the course is two-dimensional
because it's flat it's flat but it looks
like a full three-volume
thing okay so the reason why they these
physicists coined it
holographic is precisely because they're
imagining that all of the information
that is required to understand the
universe can be encoded on just
a surface as opposed to in the full
space
so for a black hole this arose because
if you look the black hole doesn't
physically have anything
at its surface but we imagine the event
horizon as a surface
the the region beyond which no
information can escape
and the idea was that everything about
the black hole
that all the information the black hole
could possibly contain
is equivalent to the amount of
information that can be packed on the
surface
and nothing more and you cannot and and
they've proven this over many years back
back since hawking you cannot have more
information than the information you can
pack on the surface
and the reason why you're saying more
information can't get into the black
hole
than can be stored on the surface of the
event horizon yes
that you can prove that the information
content of the black hole scales like
the surface area of the black hole the
event horizon and not like the volume
and so the idea would be well we could
maybe make an eye
shaking his head yeah i'm going to i did
that calculation
i i like i used to have those hologram
stickers of like caps
yeah does that get me anywhere close to
understanding
you know it's one thing to kind of think
about that but then it took really years
before people like leonard soskin
started saying
oh wait there's a very physicist he's a
physicist at stanford and just an
incredibly creative thinker
and leonard yeah and great new yorker
from the bronx it was applause
in the house in the hologram
up there i don't know if it shows up in
the thing yeah he's got that tough guy
accent still
so um so he really started to think
about this like let's say i tried to
have information that actually scaled
like the volume like that would be a lot
more information
than you would think you could pack on
the surface and you can prove that well
then you just make a black hole and we
know about black holes
fundamentally that you cannot have more
information
in the black hole then you can put on
the surface but what does it mean to put
information on a surface that does not
exist that's very subtle so it really
it's really the idea i would there's two
ways to say it one is to just say oh the
information content of the black hole
has been proven to scale like the area
and then the strength theorists started
to think well maybe that physically
means it's like
they're on the horizon that actually the
event horizon that as something falls
into the black hole
it might appear to the poor astronaut
that thinks they're falling into the
black hole
that they have crossed the event horizon
and met their fate in the interior
but to us on the outside it may appear
and this is a string theory suggestion
that it's actually
physically smeared on the outside in the
quantum
string um states that are permitted on
the outside and that it never gets
inside so what about the fact that if i
watch someone fall into a black hole
i see their time slow down yes and at
the event horizon
it has stopped exactly so can we say
that all this stops at the black hole as
far as i can see
i mean it certainly is driven by some of
those early um
confusion about that so it does seem for
as far as we're concerned it never
crosses
right um but to the astronaut themselves
they just fall straight they say all
right through
so it's literally suggesting like
quantum complementarity
created this whole there are two things
that seem incompatible that can exist at
the same time
it's literally suggesting that the
astronaut both falls in and does not
and it's smeared on the surface and
smeared on the surface but there's no
single person in the universe
who would be able to experience both
things so no single person has a
contradiction
oh i see you talk about encoding
information on the surface do you mean
like the way like there's a california
tattoo on adam levine
california yeah he's only tattoos on the
surface that's what he says
it looks like a three-dimensional body
yeah but it's really just skin tattoos
okay um so tell me something if i think
people
freeze at the surface yeah then they're
not living out their lives
we're living out our lives how could we
be and every hologram i've seen
it's a it's a frozen image it's not or
it repeats
in some trivial way see them freeze uh
you know but i'm not frozen so how can i
be a hologram
so oh i see so so um it would be
i don't think
so um it's like the end of the mary
tyler moore
opening credits where she like freezes
oh she freezes it when she flips up her
hair
is that what we're talking about how old
are you i have no aids
you're just a fan of mary tyler moore
yeah
so i would say the idea that holograms
are frozen is just a technology problem
you certainly could make a hologram
that was updating the information on the
surface and therefore moving in time
so it doesn't have to be frozen to be a
hologram but it does have to be
two-dimensional
and nonetheless appear three-dimensional
why can't we be a three-dimensional
hologram of a four-dimensional space
um
the whole game is one dimension less yes
it could be the case and there's
definitely four dimensions
there well three space in one time yeah
so
they're don't go back on us on that one
i'm not going back on you on that one
but there is some confusion about that
time dimension
but whether it behaves as a space
dimension it clearly does to sound like
it's just
full-blooded but to some extent it
doesn't because i can turn left and
right
but i i can't go in space
but i can't go forward and backward in
time right so i can't i can't do both
directions
mobility in right space and i can see
things
in both directions i can see something
to the right and i can see something to
left
i can see something in the past where
the light travels across the universe
and gets to me but i cannot see
something from the future so we
are prisoners of the present forever
trapped between a past
we cannot access in a future we cannot
see you know you said
the new opening to the twilight zone
[Laughter]
okay so that's cool so so if we so let's
get back to the question
yeah if we know just one question could
keep us busy the whole time a hundred
percent
mm-hmm if we are 100 sure that we are a
hologram
should we behave any differently uh who
are we a hologram too
yeah so this is on whose black hole
surface are we
right so then well so people have a
harder time understanding holography in
the cosmological context moving away
from the black hole
but the idea is the black hole is the
terrain on which we learn
fundamental thinking so we should use
the lessons that we can only learn there
the evidence that only exists there
to understand the whole universe as a
cue yeah as a as proxy right so then we
turn out we say oh the universe is
expanding so rapidly we have a cosmic
horizon we do
we do there is a region beyond which we
cannot see as long as the universe
expands at this pace
and the light can never get to us race
though it might because the expansion of
the universe will
will um exceed it so we are analogous
cosmologically to a black hole and we
are
inside its event it's like an inverted
one and we're inside the event horizon
and there's stuff
beyond it that we'll never know about us
and we'll never know about them
and so can we make a holography of that
and then yes can i make a holography of
just
you and i but you see we have so much
less information than the maximum we
could pack on us that that's why we
haven't tested
whether or not we're holographic animals
so a whole you know holography requires
a more sophisticated thing than just
like
printing words in a book which is not
holographic but it's way less than the
maximum amount of information
than you can pack and the hologram is an
example of packing a lot more
right so if you made a human being that
was packing the maximum amount of
information that they possibly could
they would turn into a black hole would
they have a really full backpack
so holography doesn't say you can't have
things with less information that are
just not
you know as extraordinary it just says
that's you know that's
the maximum that we can have so it's all
an illusion we really are
two-dimensional
you're flipping me out a little bit here
so just let me just say and
and i'm an astrophysicist right right so
why did you all of a sudden without
anybody's permission in this
conversation
equate matter with information
because when i think of matter
concentration of matter as
a star guy i studied stars yeah you pack
in the matter
right and you get a black hole right now
you're saying you're going to pack
information and you get an information
black hole
is that the same i think that the shift
um that i'm feeling and that i'm
learning from other people as well is
that matter is just information
so what does it mean to say an electron
is matter what we mean is it has a
certain charge
it has a certain spin it has a certain
number of quantum properties and those
quantum properties
quant qualifies information and it
completely defines what the thing is
there's no such thing as an electron
that's a little bit heavier or a little
bit lighter it spins a little faster a
little slower has a little more charge a
little less charge
there's no such thing right every
electron is identical
which one is that one yeah the only
thing that i need to know is it's
position in space
right exactly so um
the idea there is the electron is simply
the collection of
information about it and that is its
identity and so then we start to think
well what else does it mean to be
physically real is just that list of
quantum properties
so so i think that the shift is to say
look it's just math and information
and we got to stop thinking so concrete
you know feeling like
we know that this is an illusion i can't
put my hand through your leg
even though we both know it's mostly
empty space so both parts are mostly
empty
space yeah voids two voids that's the
secret to one of my tricks
i won't tell you what you're also a
magician right so
so there's a solid there's a famous
comment i'm gonna paraphrase it and
it might be apocryphal but it's great
anyway um rutherford was rutherford who
discovered um
that the atom was empty i think was
rutherford yeah i mean
yeah okay so what you do is you get a
really thin
gold foil like aluminum foil this is
gold foil hammer it really thin
and don't assume trump wraps all the
sandwiches
[Laughter]
so then you hang it there and you fire
particles at it
and you ask how often does a particle
hit a gold atom and how often does it
pass through
could you make it really really thin and
it turns out
most particles pass right through the
foil no damage done no damage done
not deflected nothing and he concluded
that
most of atoms are completely empty space
and he's rumored the next morning after
have to cut after having contemplated
this
that he was afraid to step onto the
floor
getting out of his bed fear he might
fall through
the floor because he alone on earth new
how empty matter actually is
i figured that out by looking at
republican heads
very empty reading their tweets
so in astrophysics there's something
called a degenerate state which is
not a statement about its moral fiber
most comedians are in a degenerate stage
degeneracy uh has to do with whether two
atoms or particles can occupy the same
state
at the same time the same configuration
and
electrons two identical electrons cannot
be in the same place at the same time
they have to be separated and so there's
a pressure
because they will not you know there's a
limit to how close you can get them
and now based on how you describe it i'm
thinking
if you do that you're putting too much
information in one place ooh that's an
interesting idea look at you now
so the poly exclusion principle will be
caused by
an information an information limit can
write a paper
it's an information problem i think
that's a lovely idea okay we'll talk
about that later we gotta take a break
do i get co-credit not gonna be in a
paper
yeah the credits uh yeah harrison made
us laugh
moral support i was the cheerleader so
we come back more cosmic queries
out there edition we're proud to
announce that star talk has been
nominated for the webby in the best
science and education podcast category
and we're going to need your help to win
just go to startalkradio.net webby's to
vote for star talk for the best science
and education podcast
now through april 18th we couldn't do it
without you
our fans and we certainly can't win our
first webby if you don't go
vote remember go to startalkradio.net
slash
webbies to vote we're back star talk
cosmic queries the out there edition
all parts of the universe that are far
away and freaky and
you know we've got some good expertise
for that in john 11 janet
good to have you and of course harrison
so uh this is the second segment
you're reading questions the first
segment we got through only one question
yeah but it was a doozy it was a doozy
all about holograms so what else do you
have for us this is from facebook
from nate uh guidioso guardioso
and he said could the entire known
universe be the result of a white hole
oh do you want to try it
well let me let me put white holes on
the map and then you take it from there
okay so back in the 1970s
when the mathematics of black holes was
being explored and formulated
it might have been late 1960s but it was
not deep back in the in the century it
was like
that late if you will people noticed
that the equations that give you a black
hole
have a legitimate opposite solution to
them
so let me test however let me test your
your ninth grade math knowledge you
ready okay okay what's the square root
of nine
three okay so what's 3 times 3
9. okay um
uh what's negative 3 times negative 3
also 9. so 9 has two solutions doesn't
it
right right square root of 9 is negative
3 plus or minus yeah yeah and positive
three
that's well you only gave me one
solution right the solution is preferred
right but there's the there's the dark
side
the negative side so some questions in
science the mathematics of them reveal
that there are two answers that are
completely authentic and legitimate
and when people were studying black
holes and the mathematics of black holes
a second in einstein's equations a
second solution emerged
that was everything a black hole is
except the opposite of that
so things only ever came out of this
space
and and and so
it would be white if you were to look
for it in the universe so they said
let's look for these things
and people thought maybe quasars which
are very bright distant objects in the
universe
maybe those are the white hole uh
versions of black holes and then he said
we have a white hole in black hole maybe
they're connected
and this was the introduction of a
wormhole wormhole would connect the
white hole to a black hole everything
goes into black and it comes out the
other side
so we look for the properties of a white
hole quasars did not satisfy those
properties
and uh we kind of gave up on them so no
one's looking for white holes anymore
yeah so that's that's the farthest i can
take it wait so it is
a really intuitive idea that anything
wrong i think i got
no yeah that sounds great um it it's
very
natural to imagine so let's say
everything falls into a black hole and
you think
it goes where and that's the whole
crisis about the plot hole is not
the event horizontally that's the thing
the whole crisis
i didn't know i didn't know i dropped
the w and the whole christmas and the
word must have gotten stuck in my head
so the idea would be that you can sew on
a white hole onto the interior of a
black hole and it kind of makes sense
because these singularities that people
um run amok on the streets because they
don't they don't want them to exist in
nature and they probably don't exist in
nature
and the singularities are so problematic
that wouldn't be better
instead of having this infinite energy
infinite curvature of space
infinite density infinite density
literally a hole in space like the
matter gets there in finite time
and then what you don't know what
happens to it it's literally like a cut
in space it's something where physics
breaks down fundamentally
so people had the idea well let's get
rid of the singularity and sew the black
hole onto the big bang which is also a
singularity
and so you get rid of both and and you
and you repair it
at the center of the black hole it
birthed in another universe yes so
that is casually she just said that
i'll talk about it a whole freaking
universe yeah yeah of course you got a
black hole
yeah whatever i'm still stuck on the
plus of minus negative
three what i what i love the most about
that is it means that the black hole
small as it might be on the outside so
let's say our our sun became a black
hole
um by by some intervention because it
wouldn't naturally collapse to black
holes not big enough but if it were it
would be only about six kilometers
across
a very small object on the outside but
on the inside it could be as big as a
whole universe
so it's like doctor who's about to say i
was so excited i was like
that really sounds like a turtle yeah
it's hitting the geek buttons right
there
it's bigger on the inside than the
outside suggests and one way it could be
bigger because it could be a whole big
bang it could be a whole universe
now the reason that's sort of fallen out
of favor um
is because there are reasons to suggest
that if that were true that the universe
would become very unstable to these
things
because if there's just some random
probability for
a black hole spontaneously creating a
universe in its interior it would be
even though seemingly unlikely it would
just be
such a what sort i'm looking for such a
enormous proliferation of them that it
would actually make the world unstable
and um and so it's sort of it's sort of
fallen out of favor now it depends
there's enough instability in the world
i'm all writing this for my new
screenplay for the white hole so
so some old-fashioned relativists who
only think about space and time
relativist is someone an expert on
einstein's relativity yes
and and studies primarily space time and
those who study things like string
theory and particle physics are less
are more skeptical about the idea
because their work seems to suggest this
instability
so sometimes the camps are split on this
still um
it can it's gonna be a very uh tense
dinner party
yeah so what you're saying is wherever
there's a black hole there's another
universe
if if that's the case this would be like
a swiss cheese
yes in the higher dimensional that's
right but that universe
okay so space and time switch places
interior to the black hole so while
you're imagining
a universe which is spatial the black
hole would be in its past
and therefore inaccessible so it would
look like the big bang was solely in the
past it wouldn't be a place you could go
to in the new universe
it would be a time in your history
we got to take a break and they're
they're just now getting rid of cbd
products in new york
oh man the timing is terrible no
just if i repeat what i think i heard
you just say um
if you fall into a black hole the
universe you came from
you will see the entire future history
of the universe unfold
in front of you in an instant yes so the
black hole is bright on the inside
bright bright on the ends bigger and
brighter on the inside yeah
there you go yeah all right give me
another question that's good i don't
want to let any of the alt-right know
about this white hole because they'll be
like see i told you there's another one
all right um what's your this is from a
patreon uh ken did it frank
uh contributor frank kane which i think
is he related to bob kane that's the guy
who made batman
um what's probably not but batman shout
out what's your take probably not
yeah okay uh but if a whole universe can
come out of a black hole because he's
not
batman all bets are off batman right
what is your take on negative mass i've
read that if it exists we can hold hold
open wormholes travel
backward through time make a warp drive
and all sorts of crazy stuff if the math
set is possible do you think that means
it really is possible
ooh so start there first yeah if you
have a mathematical
understanding of a theory that is
working does everything that comes out
of the math
have to be true i mean we don't
obviously know the answer to that
question but it does seem like nature
always finds a way i mean we've been
sitting here talking
about that so
black holes were originally just a
thought experiment on paper and
you know einstein thought nature would
protect us from their formation he
didn't actually think they were real he
thought the math was
accurate and beautiful and interesting
and important but not that
it he could could possibly black holes
and just
the idea was so preposterous he
literally put it he literally said oh
there's much more important things to
think about right now
and um the fact that nature figured out
a way to make them by killing off a few
stars is just kind of
amazing and it seems to happen over and
over again these seemingly implausible
concepts
um end up being challenged by our
limited uh you know our limited
intuition is challenged by by nature
actually the universe is big enough with
enough things happening
that even a completely rare thing is
going to happen
yeah or unlikely now i'm going to
contradict myself and say now if i'm
playing devil's advocate i would say
um you know the square root of 2 yes
about the square root of 9. the square
root of 2
i would say doesn't exist in physical
reality as far as we know it's only in
our minds that it exists
i can't make anything that has length
square root of two
because it will eventually end at some
finite digit which is an approximation
of square root of two
but it's not the the decimals go on
forever like y
yes irrational numbers the decimals go
on forever but
any length of anything or any
measurement of any kind will only be a
rational number and an approximate to an
irrational maybe
so we can't measure pi ever and we can't
measure anything with
with square root of two lengths and so
so that's why
you want to measure pi i want a pi with
diameter pi so it just goes on forever
you'd always be making it so you can say
well that maybe i just gave you
an example that proves that not every
mathematical concept can be realized in
physical
reality okay but i'll give you a pass on
that one i'll give you what you call in
golf what's it called uh
give you uh uh oh god you're asking me
sports questions
i remember in high school
so so all right so now yeah tell us
about negative mass
so negative mass is problematic does it
exist in anybody's
not that we know of um we have seen
negative
energies in very subtle contexts where
you have
um two plates that are very close to
each other where you can create a
negative energy in the quantum states
between the plates so these are
this is when i've dated some girls with
negative energy
so you're talking about like a capacitor
plate like metal plates yeah you get a
really really close
yeah so they're closer to each other
than the
wavelength of the particles in the
matter that comprise them yeah in some
sense
it's like saying if i can't have a water
wave between two walls
whose wavelength is longer than the
width and the width between the walls
exactly right i mean not a standing wave
and um
and so the idea is that it prunes some
energy meaning that
in some sense there's less states on the
inside because of this
than there are on the outside where you
have a whole continuum of possibilities
so that's negative energy
it can create under certain
circumstances a negative energy and then
you will see a pressure on the plates
right
there will either push part or move
together if matter and energy are
equivalent
yeah equals mc squared yeah if you're
going to give me negative energy yeah
why can't you hand me negative mass yeah
i mean it
yeah well here's okay so here's the
problem
with um with the negative mass is that
it seems highly unstable so if i
literally had a particle who's
like the electron whose fundamental mass
was literally negative
and whose e equals mt squared energy was
literally negative in that sense
um then it would be possible to make
tons of these
and balance it with the generation of
positive energy
respect conservation of energy right so
that i could get an
infinite energy resource by making
negative energy particles because that
would have to by energy conservation
lead to the creation of a positive
energy somewhere so
so run away argument when you bring them
together they annihilate and then you
have
well i don't know maybe they're not
anti-particles maybe they don't
annihilate they just might have negative
mass so
so in other words i could have zero
energy in my laboratory and i could have
the best energy company
conceivable starting with zero energy
zero energy it costs me nothing to make
negative energy particles
because i just have to create whether i
like it or not positive energy and
response
meaning i can generate incredible
positive energy with at essentially no
cost
and that is just not uh it would be so
unstable
it sounds good at first like we power
new york city at no cost
we get rid of you know fracking and coal
and getting all of these you know
fossil fuels but we also destroy the
universe
in a completely unstable event where the
negative energy runs out of control
creating infinite positive energy and
the whole thing blows up harrison i
think it was it sounds like the blood of
a supervillain
i think i seen this in a spider-man film
you were going to when
after this episode airs in one of his
books i don't remember which book
um who said the last
sentence ever spoken in the universe
was by a scientist assistant who says to
the other scientists
let's try it this other way
right this is the scenario you just
described exactly the whole universe
goes unstable and disappears so some
people say look i have an observation
that proves that there's not negative
mass particles and that's the fact that
the universe appears to be stable and
we're here
for eight you know for 14 billion years
wow
pretty good all right give me another
one all right uh we got
mike this stuff is out there square i'm
loving it this is right up my alley
i was worried you're gonna ask me about
stuff that happened more recently than
like half a
billion years ago yeah i'd be listening
to that one i'm good with that
all right we got mike barry on facebook
and he said i've never heard this
explained
if the observable universe is roughly 15
billion years old as we just said
and a star like ours lasts 12 billion
how can our sun be a third generation
star
oh so i would say 14 billion is a little
bit closer a little bit less than 14.
yeah we're we're around a third
generation star
so the life expectancy is not relevant
to what generation you are
so there because the generation that we
speak of
is we think of the stars that create the
elements
that are then scattered back into the
universe and give another generation
this enrichment those stars live hundred
thousand much shorter lives much shorter
they didn't have the heavy elements
precisely because they were first
generation yeah
so you get the the high mass stars don't
live very long
and unfortunately they blow up if they
didn't blow up they keep their heavy
elements and the carbon nitrogen oxygen
silicon that's in our bodies would be
forever locked in stars and the universe
would have never had life
would have would not have even had
planets
because these high mass stars make these
elements and explode
scattering their enrichment across the
galaxy it enables
the next generation of stars have
slightly more of this the next
generation started to have
even more so that you'd expect the
frequency of planets
and other interesting chemistry to take
place with all the elements on the
periodic table
the later your generation is the more
chemical latitude you have
this is also the story of the green
bound family previous generation living
shortly
exploding and you are particularly
enriched
a lot of chemical latitude we got time
for one more before we take a break
sure uh we got jezebel lorelei from
facebook and she writes
what's this that's a real name jezebel
yeah
that's a movie name right there what's
the smallest a black hole can be and is
there a name for the atom that is one
neutron less
than that atomic weight wait say the
last part again
is there an atom on the periodic table
that's one neutron less than that atomic
weight
so it's what's the smallest of black
hole it can be and then is there a name
for an atom that has one
neutron less than that weight um it's
definitely less than a neutrons wait
what so no wait actually it's not all
those two are those two different
questions
there's a comma and another it's a comma
okay they've been jammed together
don't you know the trick of answering
the question you can and want to yeah
regardless
which one you're using she knows she can
answer okay go
so um
so we do know that it is conceivable
well we don't okay
it is conceivable that uh a microscopic
black hole could be made
under very extraordinary conditions now
we say that the limit of the mass of it
is related to the strength of gravity
and that gives us a scale of how how
heavy it could be
and it's heavy compared to things like
electrons
but it's incredibly light compared to um
golf balls anything right else on the uh
exactly
so i think it's about the weight of a
little pile of sand
imagine a modest pile of sand that would
be about the weight it could maintain
and be consistent with what we think is
the limit of the strength of gravity and
it would be
an incredibly tiny microscopic black
hole i mean i can't even
i i'm oh yeah it'd be really small
um but wait i should know the number 10
to the
what what is it 10 to the minus 45
seconds
after the big bang is around the time of
quantum gravity so if i multiply that
maybe by the speed of light i would
roughly get
the size of the black hole or something
like that but anyway you can ask me ask
me later i'll crunch some numbers okay
10 to the minus 15 meters or something
so but but
black holes evaporate so they can become
so small that they don't exist at all
those oh good point so those black holes
are incredibly unstable to evaporation
because the um the idea that hawking uh
wasted on stephen hawking the late
stephen hawking um the amazing stephen
hawking
that black holes although they let
nothing out they somehow still evaporate
that tremendous paradox that we've been
grappling with since the 70s
um he also realized that the temperature
is colder the bigger the black hole
so they evaporate more slowly the bigger
they are so we've never seen an
astrophysical black hole evaporate
because they're way too cold for us to
proceed
the big ones that are made by dead stars
a microscopic one made in the early
universe would presumably evaporate in
an instant
and it would be it would so people have
looked for that they've looked for
little explosions
high energy explosions in the very early
universe gamma-ray bursts
black holes small bursts yeah we haven't
found them though yeah yeah
oh right yeah we gotta wrap up this
segment
of cosmic queries the out-there edition
we'll be right back
help star talk win a webby award vote
now
at starttalkradio.net slash
webbies star talk cosmic queries the out
there edition
this is the first time we've done an out
there edition i think we have to do this
more often this is fun and janet you're
like a neighbor
up the street yeah at barnard in
colombia yeah yeah so we'll just say
i just take a stroll yeah yeah we'll
have to like have a little bat signal
are you out there we need you here for
an out there uh
ed harrison again thanks for being on
star talk so you got
cosmic queries first what more do you
have uh we got let's make this entire
segment the lightning round
all right oh we're going to be finished
you used to give me a bell i don't know
what happened to my bell
um but a lightning round so this will
just be more soundbite answers just so
we can get to more questions
okay absolutely we have tony underscore
le738 on instagram
says they're an opposite to a black hole
that just spews out things
white hole there's a lot
been there done that yeah they just
spews out endless garbage trump okay
um ben ratner at ben makes tv on twitter
what is your favorite recipe for a good
soup
ooh it would be primordial soup
nice i didn't mean to step on your
announcement
i was reading it out loud oh yeah for me
a good soup would be
all the basic ingredients
that are the foundational to
biochemistry
carbon nitrogen oxygen
carbon is the stickiest element on the
entire table
it can make more kinds of molecules than
any other
elements combined so give me a soup with
carbon nitrogen oxygen in it
and i can show you life can you read the
ingredients on the primordial syrup the
ingredients i used to be able to see
uh is this a real oh yeah okay
uh quick and easy instructions mix soup
one can of sea water
okay lightning heat
uncovered in early years it's just like
the early earth here
um for two to three millennia
save the simple molecules
to form larger more complex molecules
for a creamier soup use one can of
organisms
so yeah that's that so that'd be the
best kind of soup at all
i prefer a split pea all right keep
going here all right we got joshua
wilhelm from facebook
are you still in quick mode lightning
mob if you could subtly know the answer
to any question what question would you
choose
subtly knowing the answer is so
disappointing as a scientist the whole
font is figuring it out
i don't know if i'd subtly want to know
the answer to any question other than
when's my uber coming or something
i think you just have to look at your
phone yeah that's not a mystery on that
one
they have physics that are unbelievable
where like the car just jumps through a
building and you're like that was
that was some physical possibility or
just does it flip around and
you know over discover a black hole in
the city i don't know how it jumped
a wormhole through the building so for
me
the answer i want is to the question
we don't know yet to ask
[Music]
would you recognize it if you heard it
because the day we learn what that
question is
i no longer care i will wait await the
day
where the next question comes that i
didn't know to ask and it's
this is strongly resonant with jana's
answer where
the quest to the science is not so much
about answers but
the search for answers and that's where
you
learn you stumble on things you discover
the structures of things you didn't even
know
that was a question you needed to ask so
yeah i'm all i'm all into the search
so these are i'd like to have the answer
just not suddenly
very good that's a very healthy posture
otherwise there's a psychological
problem
yeah exactly i get an escape room so
within 60 minutes that's really when i
need the answers
all right we got scott york and
instagram could dark matter or dark
energy
be any indication of alien technology
that is beyond human comprehension
ooh go don't look at me
this feels more like in the end okay
here's what i was i'll give my answer
and
i want to hear your answer okay just
because
there's something in the universe we
don't understand doesn't mean it's
aliens
it doesn't mean it's magic otherwise my
vcr was made by aliens
you still have a vcr exactly the fact
that we really need
reflect alien intervention somehow you
talk about mary tyler moore and you're
talking about vcrs
how the hell old are you guys i'm sorry
my beaver went off
[Laughter]
so um so i think
right now what was the question again uh
could dark matter and dark energy be
evidence of aliens it's tempting it's
always tempting to ascribe something
completely extraordinary as the cause
for something we don't understand
we've been doing that forever but as a
scientist you have to resist that
because the history of that exercise
is one of abject failure persistently
so to say oh it's actually magic or it's
actually god
or it's actually an alien and then you
study it and it's
it's reducible to known forces or maybe
you'll discover a new force but it's
still not magic
it's still not god and it's still not
aliens so
if i'm betting i would say it's probably
not as much as we would really love it
to be
now the place we should be looking for
aliens is a place we actually know where
to look which is on exoplanets and
that's where
there really is a very serious prospect
that there are aliens now these are
planets orbiting other stars
yes exactly planets orbiting other stars
we think that in our
uh milky way of which there are hundreds
of billions of stars that there are
probably more planets than there are
stars in the milky way
and so um that's suddenly a stunning
number that we didn't realize what 20
years ago yeah but you're just talking
about some kind of
living organism right i was going to say
we're talking about aliens
serious right it's reagan aliens you
know absolutely they're
they're aliens right now they're
probably
more like
that's so you're so unfun with that it's
true but underneath
a book that says how to serve man but
that is a cookbook
all right uh k fudge from instagram how
many black holes are there
kate fudge k-fudge okay excuse me i
thought you said kate fudge
somebody's hungry all right how many
black holes are there
so in our galaxy we just said that there
were a few hundred billion stars in our
galaxy
about one percent of that them at the
end of their lives are going to be big
enough to collapse all the way through
to become black holes and so
that's a lot right yeah one percent of a
hundred billion is a billion blocks
billion black holes and in addition to
that we know that there are tens of
thousands of black holes
around the supermassive black hole the
center of our galaxy
so the center of our galaxy harbors a
black hole a few million times the mass
of the sun and it has tens of thousands
of black holes specially segregated
around it so that's just our galaxy now
you're saying
in the observable universe or as many
galaxies as our stars in the milky way
you got a lot of black holes out there
and and all evidence shows that every
red-blooded galaxy like the milky way
has got a supermassive black hole in its
center so
we've got hundreds of billions of those
and hundreds of billions
times a billion of the reg of the
smaller ones
surrender now the worst milky way
like the milky way candy bar that's
realistic has a black hole in the middle
of it
no thank you uh on the black hole
tangent
tony uh oh sorry uh geek.2
at instagram wrote can a black hole eat
another black hole and if so would it
contribute to its growth
absolutely a pac-man theory of black
holes absolutely one of them
what you your references are so pac-man
classic oh
i love it but i have to make fun of it
because we gotta can we come to your
house
and see what you've got the setup there
i've done a couple of 80s escape rooms
recently so it's awesome
oh yeah black hole is eating other black
holes that is we one of the most
exciting things that's happened this
entry
is the direct recording of the sound of
space-time ringing
uh due to the collision of two black
holes which
if you want to call it them eating each
other you could they merged and they
created
a bigger black hole so each one was
about 30 times the mass the sun and so
we know that there's a black hole out
there in that
rough direction as far as we can
ascertain that is 60 times
the mass of the sun and yes they get
bigger they get bigger by almost as much
as you would think
the energy that they lost in terms of
like literally e equals mc squared
energy that wasn't the sum of the parts
came out in this ringing of space-time
and it was recorded by ligo
this fantastic instrument it happened in
a new window
to the universe that's measuring the
ripples in the fabric of space
rather than the ripples and the energy
of light and this is what black hole
blues was all about i was writing it
while they were on this campaign yeah
and they hadn't succeeded while i was
writing and i was really writing it
precisely ties in with what we were
talking about earlier about the pursuit
and you know it was 50 long years that
they strove
to build this instrument wait a minute
the title of your book is black hole
blues is that because you didn't think
they would find it yeah
and then they found it and now your book
has the wrong title yeah so
amazingly ray wise who won the nobel
prize alongside kip thorne and barry
barish for that discovery
said to me about a month before the
detection occurred
if we don't detect black holes this
thing is a failure and so i got the
title really thinking about ray saying
that
that he's now in his 80s he started this
as a young man
and um and it was the black hole blues
but they told me
well before the book you know came out
they told me about the detection so
i didn't want to rewrite it because i
think it is all about the pursuit but i
do have a lovely close
where they make the discovery okay i
didn't get to that close yet
now i'm gonna go let's go ahead to find
it all right give me more
all right uh we got michelle achimpora
from facebook if everything is supposed
to be expanding away from each other
how come our galaxy is on a collision
course with andromeda okay i got this
i got this i'm gonna have to throw down
afterwards i got this
uh so the expansion of the universe is
think of it as a stretchy fabric
that if and it doesn't matter where you
are
you'll think you're at the center of
that stretching and you'll see objects
moving away from you in every direction
objects that are near you will not be
moving away as fast
as objects that are farther away because
every let's say for every
meter it stretches 10 centimeters okay
well that means at 2 meters it stretches
20 centimeters at 3 meters it's 30
centimeters that's how stretching works
in the fabric so
all galaxies have speeds relative to
each other
if you have a nearby galaxy it's going
faster
than the stretching speed of the
universe
in this space in the space near me so
my gravity overcomes anything the
universe is doing
for things nearby so nearby galaxies are
going on like the universe is not
expanding they don't really care
their gravity is strong enough to create
motions that overcome
the expansion of the universe itself but
we're not going to collide with a
distant galaxy because this
stretching of the universe is taking us
away faster than that can never happen
i just wanted to make a reference to i
think it's annie hall
the line where um the character
um won't do his homework because he's
he's
because the universe is expanding and
he's and his mother's mother says you
live in brooklyn brooklyn
is not expanding and it's true brooklyn
is not expanding for precisely the
reasons neil just gave
that that the earth is bound together
more strongly than the expansion
universe in this in this section this
expanding universe is not going to break
apart the earth
yeah but now a bunch of developers have
brought brooklyn and it is expanding at
an incredible place
all right so we got uh it's gonna be
fast kyle toth from venice florida
uh what lies been beyond the observable
universe do we have an estimated size of
the entire
universe oh i love this jana take it and
by the way
we were still kind of in speed mode yeah
but we're going to end with your answer
to this question
okay okay no problem
um it is conceivable uh that the
universe is actually finite
and the same sense that the earth is
finite if i leave new york city and i
walk in as straight a line as possible
and i go for as long as i possibly can i
come back to new york city again
um it is conceivable without ever
falling off an edge without ever turning
left or right falling off an edge going
forward and backward so you can walk
forward forever forward forever and just
keep coming back around and around and
around again
now if the whole universe is like this i
literally would leave the milky way in a
spacecraft
i would travel in a straight line watch
the galaxy received behind me not turn
left not turn right never stop forward
not fall off the edge of the universe
but see the milky way approach in front
of me again
wow how long how many how many points
drop on that right here
how many seasons of this podcast would
you have to listen to before you start
the milky way again
that's right we would look back and
because light
has a finite travel time we would hear
podcasts from our past like you could
look back
and see yourself as a child if you
waited long enough for the light
to come back around again from the other
direction from the other direction yeah
and um and so we could actually resolve
serious
quandaries by being like well if we wait
a billion years we can actually watch it
again
just to get the arguments straight about
who said what exactly over dinner
who broke the plane right there's a
saddle
like i told you janice this was all
worth it
so so okay so that's a finite universe
but
just as equally the universe could be
infinite and we're just our own
observable pocket
within some infinite universe right it
is also possible and that the universe
is infinite and beyond the observable
universe is this infinite stretch of
space but you know einstein said only
two things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity
and then he said i'm not sure about the
universe
that sounds like we should end on that
no it doesn't matter
well that was a cosmic queries out there
edition our very first on that theme
but clearly we're gonna have to do this
again because there's no end to those
kind of questions
particularly we get janna kind of
answers right there
janet it's great and i've been loving
your book black hole the black hole
blues
thank you harrison thanks for coming
back on star trek my pleasure and
harrisongreenbound.com we'll look for
your where you
for your stand-up gigs and you're also a
magician absolutely
like as you said that's the double
threat
very common very common very common and
i've been your host neil degrasse tyson
this has been star talk
and as always i bid you to keep looking
up
hey star talk fans now that the show's
over please remember to go and vote
for star talk to win the webby for the
best science and education podcast
you can go to star talk radio dot net
slash webby's
to vote right now